on retrouve jean de gliniasty diplomate
ancien ambassadeur de france en russie
et auteur de l'ouvragé petite histoire
des relations franco-russes bonjour
comment analysez-vous la riposte des
occidentaux à l'invasion russe en
ukraine
ben je crois car ils passent des
occidentaux c'est le maximum que l'on
puisse faire sans entrer dans le statut
de kobe l'hygiène et les positions
évoluent puisque volodymyr zelensky
président ukrainien a déclaré qu'il ne
demandait plus l'adhésion à l'otan et
les européens à versailles ont décidé
hier de renforcer leur aide à l'ukraine
mais refuse d'ouvrir une procédure
accélérée d'adhésion
oui mais c'est très difficile pour
l'union européenne de de lancer une
procédure accélérée d'adhésion d'abord
les les procédures sont compliquées et
puis ensuite il ya aussi ce fameux
article 47 que tout le monde connaît
maintenant qui est en fait l'équivalent
de 45 du traité de lisbonne
qui est l'équivalent de l'article 5 de
de l'otan et qui en fait prévoit un
engagement automatique aux côtés du deux
des membres de de l'union européenne qui
sont attaqués donc c'est une difficulté
supplémentaire
selon vous actuellement que vise
vladimir poutine soumettre l'ensemble de
l'ukraine à son pouvoir ou imposer une
partition entre l'est et l'ouest
alors évidemment c'est très difficile de
le dire il ya une chose qui est sûre
c'est qu'ils ne cherchent un quai vers
un gage suffisamment importants pour
pouvoir négocier en position de force et
le drame du peuple ukrainien c'est que
ce gage il n'estime pas l'avoir
actuellement donc il va continuer quand
il aura estimé qu'il a suffisamment
d'atouts dans sa main en terme de
territoire et de démantèlement de de
l'armée et des infrastructures
ukrainienne à ce moment-là peut-être et
négociera qu'est ce qu'il voudra
négocier là c'est difficile soit
effectivement une partie sur l'ukraine
mais je ne crois pas que ils y
parviennent puisque en fait le peuple
régnier a gagné dans le sang le droit
d'exister en tant que nation unifiant
les différentes parties du pays
mais il peut essayer de négocier des
garanties de sécurité celle qu'il a
demandé lui-même depuis 20 ans et donc
ça c'est pas pour tout de suite ces
négociations il me semble évident le
pardon allez-y hélas non
il me semble évident que l'élargissement
de l'otan c'est une provocation qui sape
la confiance mutuelle et nous pouvons
légitimement nous demande et contre qui
cet élargissement est dirigé c'est ce
qu'a déclaré vladimir poutine en 2007 à
munich la demande d'adhésion de
l'ukraine à l'otan elle est peut-être un
prétexte mais en tout cas depuis 15 ans
vladimir poutine parle de son opposition
à l'extension vers l'est de l'otan
en effet c'est une des constantes de son
discours qui l'a porté jusqu'à l'extrême
puisqu'il a fait 7 cette sanglante et
tragique bêtise d'attaqué l'ukraine et
de et de la séparer à tout jamais de la
russie enfin on dit jamais jamais mais
en tout cas pour plusieurs générations
mais au moins sur ce plan on ne peut pas
lui refuser le mérite de la cohérence il
a toujours dit que pour lui l'entrée de
l'ukraine dans le temps elles étaient 1
il n'a pas dit un casus belli mais en
fait une ligne rouge il l'a dit et est
ce que vous pensez qu'il existait puisse
se développer une opposition à la guerre
parmi les décideurs et l'intelligentsia
russe
elle existe déjà je pense qu'il y a peu
de
peu de classe moyenne de 2 décideurs ou
d'appels kane sall comme vous le dit à
juste titre qu'ils ne soient pas
extrêmement réticents voire carrément
hostiles à la guerre
le problème c'est que c'est une minorité
poutine est appuyée sur une base
sociologique importante tous ceux qui
travaillent pour l'état tout ce tous les
ruraux 30% de la population qui
n'écoutent que la télévision russe
officiel et comme vous le savez il n'ya
plus de médias
l'officiel pratiquement donc donc il a
une base sociologique forte ce qui fait
que ça mettra du temps interpellé avant
que les réserves voire l'hostilité d'une
partie de l'opinion à l'invasion de
l'ukraine se traduisent en politiquement
donc vous pensez que la population russe
elle soutient l'invasion de l'ukraine
décidé par vladimir poutine dans son
ensemble
je ne crois pas qu'elles soutiennent
vraiment l'invasion de l'ukraine puisque
comme vous le savez il ya plus d'un
tiers de russes qui sont devant une
paire père une mère ukrainienne une
tente en fait les liens sont très
étroits donc sur le fond ça doit les
choquer mais le premier mouvement des
russes c'est de serrer les rangs autour
du chef quand ils pensent que la russie
est menacé par par exemple les sanctions
et le monde occidental et c'est donc ce
premier réflexe obsidionale
se manifeste plus tôt actuellement quand
on regarde les sondages on voit que la
popularité de poutine n'a pas baissé
elle a plutôt tendance à augmenter ça
c'est le premier stade et puis après les
comptes se règlent merci beaucoup jean
de gliniasty pour votre analyse et merci
d'avoir été avec nous sur france 24